this video was made possible by hover
get your unique domain and email from
hover by going to hover calm slash
second thought
in a past video we looked at how many
nukes it would take to eradicate human
life on earth it was a big number but
what if we wanted to go even further is
it possible to blow up the entire earth
and if so how could we do it the earth
is no pushover our home planet has
existed for over four-and-a-half billion
years and has likely suffered more
cataclysms than we know
including one collision with an object
so massive it blasted away parts of the
earth which eventually came together to
form our moon if an object roughly the
size of Mars couldn't destroy the earth
how could we possibly do it let's take a
look at the tools we have on hand
there are approximately 15,000 active
nuclear weapons scattered around the
globe with a total yield of about 6,500
megatons
or 6 billion 500 million tons of TNT
that sounds like a lot and it is but
unfortunately for anyone trying to blow
up the planet it wouldn't even scratch
the earth on a global scale by
comparison the Chicxulub impact event
the collision thought to be the cause of
the mass extinction 65 million years ago
released over 100 million megatons of
energy that's over 15,000 300 times the
world's nuclear output and even that
gigantic explosion didn't affect the
planet climate in the long term so no
not even the entirety of the world's
nuclear arsenal could cause the total
destruction of the earth not by a
longshot but what if we were absolutely
intent on using nuclear weapons to blow
up the planet how many would it take to
answer that we need to consider what's
called the Earth's gravitational binding
energy which is the cumulative strength
of the planets gravity holding itself
together the Earth's binding energy is
roughly 2.2 4 times 10 to the 32nd
joules which is enormous ly powerful the
current nuclear arsenal could
hypothetically generate 2 point 6 7
times 10 to the 19th joules of energy
which is a lot but still 1 million
billion times too weak to blow up the
planet if we replaced each currently
available nuclear warhead with the Tsar
Bomba the largest nuclear device ever
detonated we would need over 1
quadrillion bombs as you might have
guessed making that many nuclear weapons
is simply beyond the reach of our
current technology not to mention the
fact that we would likely run out of
materials before we got anywhere close
to 1 quadrille
in bombs okay so nukes are out what
could we create that's even more
destructive if we're willing to use more
exotic materials we could hypothetically
generate enough antimatter to blast the
earth into thousands of fragments
antimatter is strange and still largely
a mystery to scientists but think of it
like this if you take a positive one and
a negative one then add them together
you are left with zero or nothing
that's how matter and antimatter react
with one another in a nutshell
antimatter has so much destructive
potential that just one gram could
create a bomb the equivalent of the
warhead dropped on Hiroshima in World
War two of course destroying a city is
one thing but blasting an entire planet
that pieces is something entirely
different in order to create a warhead
powerful enough to destroy the earth
we'd need to create and harness the
power of 25 trillion tons of antimatter
so while this method hypothetically
could be possible it would require an
enormous amount of antimatter to work
properly as of right now scientists have
only managed to create and store a few
hundred antimatter atoms at our current
technology level it would take about 10
billion years to make one gram so like
nukes antimatter can be ruled out due to
time and scale constraints our first two
ideas may not be possible with our
current capabilities but we are not out
of options just yet if we're still
intent on physically breaking the earth
apart then causing a collision with a
very fast very massive object might do
the trick
technically you wouldn't even need the
object to be super massive just like a
cannon ball fired from a cannon does
more damage than one thrown by hand a
relatively small asteroid could work if
it were accelerated to high enough
speeds say 90% of the speed of light as
difficult and unlikely as that would be
to be sure of the planets destruction
we'd need something much much larger
than any known asteroid in the early
days of the Earth's existence the planet
was struck by an object roughly the size
of Mars breaking apart some of its mass
and eventually giving birth to our moon
in order to cause even more damage and
break the earth apart completely we'd
need an object the size of Mars
traveling at a speed of about 50
kilometers per second venus is another
great candidate for our kinetic warhead
weighing in at roughly 81 percent of the
Earth's mass considerably more than Mars
is 11% of course we'd have to
solve the problem of how to actually
accelerate a planet to such high speeds
and lock it into a collision course with
earth
one method would be to use gravitational
assists redirecting a steady stream of
asteroids to swing around our giant
billiard ball slowly nudging it into the
correct trajectory is it possible
theoretically yes whether we could be
accurate enough and generate sufficient
speed to blast the earth to bits is
another question so if you still want to
tackle the massive challenge of
annihilating the earth
you've got your options 1 quadrillion
nuclear warheads 25 trillion tons of
antimatter or a cosmic cannonball the
size of Mars whatever you choose it
would be nice to give the humans of
Earth a little warning perhaps by
creating a web site with a fitting name
like exploding dot earth hover makes it
easy to buy all kinds of custom domains
with fun extensions like Earth or dot
space but here's the best part
even if you don't need a website you can
just set up a custom email account with
an exploding dot earth email address the
rest of the world will have to take you
seriously for award-winning customer
support and over 400 domain extensions
to choose from make sure to visit
hover.com slash second thought and save
10% on your diabolical new domain and
email address if you enjoyed this video
make sure to subscribe to keep up to
date with the latest content and click
the little bell next to my channel name
to be notified every time I release a
new video you can watch my previous
video by clicking here or if you're
really bored you can watch all my videos
by clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]